in 1951 doctors took a tissue sample
from a poor dying black woman that was
given to researchers without her
knowledge or her permission the HeLa
cells names for the patient's first and
last name acted differently than other
cells in the lab there were hardian and
they replicated at an amazing rate they
also didn't die cultivation of HeLa
launched a revolution in biomedical
research and a multi-billion dollar
industry the cells were sold all over
the world and led to important advances
to fight humankind's deadliest diseases
including polio HIV and cancer no one
aside from the patient's doctors and
lead researchers knew the origins of the
HeLa cells not her name or anything else
about her life two decades passed before
this mystery woman was revealed and it
was many more years before her family
had answers to their most burning
questions today we examined the woman
behind the notorious and immortal HeLa
cells Henrietta Lacks
[Music]
on August the 1st 1920 eliza lacks
pleasant gave birth to a baby girl
Loretta in a shack at the end of a
dead-end road in Roanoke Virginia at
some point during her life Loretta
changed her name to Henrietta though no
one knows why the shack overlooking the
train depot was the young girl's home
until her mother tragically died
Henrietta at this point was only four
years old Eliza passed from this life to
the next during childbirth with her
tenth baby leaving her husband Johnny a
widow unable to take care of all the
children he sent them away to live with
family 125 miles southeast from Raonic
in southern Virginia the lacs family
lived in the town of plover just past
difficult Creek on the banks of the
river of death now this might sound like
a bad omen but in the 1920s it looked
like a lot of small towns in rural
Virginia on the outskirts fields of
tobacco and old plantation houses dotted
the rolling hills and on Main streets
down the dusty roads the town buzzed
with life there was a movie theater
grocery store post office shops
restaurants and a train depot
Henrietta wouldn't recognize the town
today clover lost so many US residents
by the late 1990s that it's official
Charter was revoked in the last census
in 2010 the population had dwindled to a
mere 438 when Johnny came to town in
1924 Henrietta and ten nine brothers and
sisters had to be divided up amongst the
relatives no one could take all ten
children
Henrietta ended up living with her
grandfather Tommy lacks in a four-roomed
log cabin calls the home house
generations of Laxus have lived and died
they're buried in the small family plot
Henrietta could see out of her window
formerly slave quarters the home house
was a simple structure with no
electricity or indoor plumbing only gas
lanterns and water that Henriette hauled
up from the creek below Tommy it was
already caring for another grandchild
nine-year-old Dale acts when Henrietta
came to live at the home house the
children shared a room then worked every
day together planting and harvesting the
tobacco and tending to the animals and
the garden after the day's work they
sometimes swam in the swimming hole and
bonfires at night and played
ring-around-the-rosy with their cousins
once a month during harvest grandpa
Tommy and the cousins headed to South
Boston to the second largest tobacco
market in the nation to sell their crop
it was a time they all looked forward
even if the market wasn't a safe place
for children with its free-flowing booze
prostitution and the occasional murder
at the home house Henriette awoke every
morning at 4 o'clock to milk the cows
and feed the pigs when she was finished
with her morning chores she walked two
miles to the schoolhouse four colored
children passed the white school where
children threw rocks at her and called
her name's Jim Crow laws segregated
blacks from whites and that remained in
place until 1964 in the short 31 years
of her life it was all she knew by sixth
grade Henriette walked to the
schoolhouse one last time like day and
the other Laxus she dropped out to work
in the tobacco fields
[Music]
few public photos of Henrietta Lacks
exist the most well-known is a striking
image from a 1970s Rolling Stone article
of a smiling smartly dressed woman in a
skirt suit jacket and open toe sandals
her hands are firmly placed on her hips
until Walmart eyes glimmer at the camera
she looks self-assured with a hint of
mischief spread about in her grin it's
obvious even by today's standards that
Henrietta was beautiful she was the envy
of other women and desirable to all of
the men around her it wasn't only her
beauty that attracts people to Henrietta
her cousin cootie described eras
lovey-dovey as kind as she was pretty
always taking care of family and friends
and neat as a child cootie had been
stricken with polio and Henrietta took
care of him when it got bad everyone who
knew her remembers Henrietta as a gentle
caregiver and a strong woman
even when cancer was spreading inside
her body she didn't make a fuss or draw
attention to herself very few people
knew until the end quite how she
suffered Henrietta had no shortage of
men vying for her affection as a young
woman Henrietta
chose day her cousin with whom she
shared a bedroom and had spent countless
hours with since the age of four they
had their first baby a boy named
Lawrence out of wedlock when Henrietta
was barely 14 years old he was born on
the Home House floor like his father
owns numerous cousins aunts and uncles
and grandparents before another likes
baby Elsie was born four years later
eventually Henrietta and des said their
vows in a private marriage ceremony on
April the 10th 1941 she was 21 and he
was 25
by the winter of 1941 the country was at
war and small tobacco farms including
Henrietta and days were barely making
enough to make ends meet but to the
north there was opportunity in the
booming factories demand for steel was
increasing a great migration of black
families came to turn a station Maryland
leaving behind the southern farms at
Bethlehem Steel Sparrow Point in
Baltimore County a black man could make
up to 80 cents an hour the most any of
the Laxus have seen in factories
Blackmon took the jobs white men
rejected and they were exposed to a host
of toxic chemicals including asbestos
when the men finished their shifts and
returned home the toxins were shared
with their wives and children through
their clothes at the urging of Laxus
cousin who was doing well for himself a
spare appoint den Henrietta moved with
their babies to Turner station
starting a new life other cousins made
the transition to including Henrietta's
close friend Sadie the city was a change
for the LAX's but they adjusted and they
had fun after cleaning cooking and
taking care of the children Henrietta
and Sadie would put on their dancing
shoes and sneak out until the wee hours
the two women boogies laughed and had a
great time and when they went dancing
Henrietta Sadie and Sadie sister
Margaret played bingo in Henry at his
living room Turner station was new and
exciting but Henrietta preferred the
country whenever she could she rode the
train back to clover to work in the
fields or chanbara on the home house
porch
it was here her eldest daughter Elsie
was most at ease
Elsie it inherited her mother's good
looks but she was born special unable to
speak or talk she made chirps and course
sounds like the birds and sometimes
flailed her arms in front of her face
years later it was understood that Elsie
had epilepsy and cognitive developmental
delays that left her unable to
communicate no one knew what was going
on in a pretty head at home in Turner
station Elsie was known to occasionally
run out into the street screaming
by the time Henrietta was pregnant with
her fifth baby Elsie had grown stronger
and this made it near impossible for her
mother to take care of her to make life
easier doctors recommended Henrietta
commit I'll see to the Crownsville state
hospital formerly the hospital for the
negro insane believing the doctors knew
best Henrietta institutionalized her
daughter years later family members said
part of Henrietta died the day she left
LC at Crownsville Henrietta routinely
visited her daughter once a week at the
hospital before she became ill after
Henrietta died no one ever went to
Crownsville to see LC again
[Music]
Henrietta was certain there was
something wrong with her a year and a
half before her official cervical cancer
diagnosis she shared her worry with her
cousin Sadie and Margaret saying there
was a knot inside and explaining how it
hurts something awful and that man want
to get with me sweet Jesus aren't them
but some pains whoo women poked her
stomach over and over and felt nothing
maybe it was a baby growing inside they
suggested to be sure that nothing was
seriously wrong her cousins tried to
convince Henrietta to see a doctor but
she didn't and about a week later Henry
also found out she was pregnant the
ladies Maria shorter that it was just
the baby making her feel funny but
Henrietta wasn't convinced nevertheless
she didn't bring it up with Sadie and
Margaret again and the women never
mentioned the conversation with anyone
else
Henrietta carried her fifth baby
determined after Joe was born she wasn't
feeling any better one day alone in the
bathroom she slipped into the bathtub
and reached inside herself she could
feel the knot and told day she needed to
go and see a doctor on a referral from a
local physician Henrietta went to Johns
Hopkins Hospital to seek answers at this
point Henrietta thought the doctors
would simply fix her right up on January
the 29th 1951 Daedra of Henrietta with
their three small children 20 miles from
Turner station to Johns Hopkins Johns
Hopkins was not only a hospital it was a
renowned Medical Research Center it also
had a public Ward serving patients who
were too poor to afford treatment many
of whom were black in the 1950s under
discriminatory segregation laws in the
United States black patients could be
turned away at hospitals doctors offices
and clinics that served white patients
sometimes the consequences were dire
including death Johns Hopkins was
Henrietta's best and only real option
for diagnosis and treatment of cervical
cancer while tape sat in the car with
their small children waiting for
Henrietta to return she met dr. Howard
Jones the gynecologist on duty
in the exam room he reviewed her medical
history and listened to Henrietta
described the lump that she felt inside
her when Jones examined her he found a
hard mass about the size of a nickel the
tumor was the color of grape jello
exactly in the spot Henriette said it
would be decades later in his nineties
Jones recalled never seen anything like
Henrietta's tumor during his years
practicing medicine not before and not
since
during the exam dr. James cut a tiny
sample of the tumor to test and confirm
what he suspected was cancerous then he
sent Henrietta back home to Turner
station to await the results Jones
thought it was odd that Henrietta had
had a full-term baby just a few months
prior with no notes mentioning the tumor
or any abnormalities of the cervix
listed in her chart it was unlikely
physicians would have missed seeing it
which meant it must have grown at an
alarming rate a few days later
Henrietta received the results back from
the lab epidermoid carcinoma of the
cervix stage one
in 1951 there was standard practice to
conduct research on public ward hospital
patients without consent explicit
permission or informed consent from
patients wasn't a term that was coined
and so no legal or ethical standard
existed in the United States for
obtaining it at Hopkins the then leading
cervical cancer expert in the world and
dr. Jones's boss Richard to Lindh
believed that since the patients were
treated free of charge the research was
a form of payment for the hospital
services when Henrietta went in for her
exam a sample from Henrietta's tumor was
sent to George gays lab that of tissue
culture research at Hopkins without n
knowledge for years gay had been trying
unsuccessfully to grow and keep alive
human cells outside of the body in Petri
dishes culturing cells allowed
scientists to test their response to all
kinds of drugs diseases and conditions
in order to understand how the human
body would react the benefit of this was
that it didn't cause any harm to the
patient's when Henrietta went to Hopkins
an agreement was already in place to
provide gays research lab with patients
cancerous tumor samples primarily to be
used in studies to prove to Lynne's
theories telland was a believer that of
the two types of cervical cancer the
non-invasive variety carcinoma in situ
could spread and become deadly this was
contrary to what the majority of
researchers thought at the time and
physicians practices followed this
conclusion treating only the invasive
cancers aggressively he actually had
another motive for his research using
cells too so Linda wanted to reduce the
number of unjustifiable hysterectomies
by detecting what wasn't cervical cancer
at all the pap smear test used to
identify changes to a woman's cervical
cells was developed only a decade
earlier but few physicians could
interpret the results and treat patients
accordingly in extreme cases a woman who
just needed a few antibiotics declare up
a minor infection might have had her
entire uterus removed in a surgical
procedure when Gaye's lab assistant Mary
received Henrietta's tissue sample she
had every reason to believe the cells if
they lived at all would die within a few
days she was eating lunch and decided to
finish her sandwich first so far even
with Gaye's standards meticulous process
and emphasis on sterilization his lab
had little success with growing human
cells when Mary got to work on Henry at
his cancer cells she carefully and
precisely sliced the samples with steady
hands
the media the cells would need to grow
and labeled them healer for the first
two letters of Henrietta's first and
last names then she left them alone not
really expecting very much by the next
morning to Mary's surprise Henrietta's
cells had divided and in the days ahead
healer kept making copies of themselves
they grew unlike any cells before and
expanded into as much space as Mary
would give them Gaye was ecstatic
because the cells were growing like
crabgrass and soon among researchers
word was out about the amazing HeLa
cells everyone knew the implications for
furthering biomedical research and this
was Gaye's goal soon he began sending
HeLa cells to any scientist interested
in using them for their own studies
[Music]
Henrietta's treatment first cervical
cancer which radium a radioactive metal
that glows blue and is highly toxic in
the early 20th century upon radium's
discovery it was hailed as a miracle to
cure all kinds of ailments now
radiant does kill cancer cells but it
can burn skin from a person's body if
it's given in high enough quantities
being radioactive well radium it also
causes cancer in 1951 the radium
treatment for cervical cancer involved
placing tubes inside the patient's next
to the affected area common side effects
include nausea vomiting weakness and
anemia if henrietta experienced any of
these she didn't let on or seemed sick
at all after treatment started Henrietta
finally told the same cousins she
confided in about the knot inside her
scheana wants anyone to worry but the
frequent visits to Johns Hopkins would
mean she would be away and people would
certainly wonder initially the radium
treatment seemed to work and doctors
recorded the tumor as having vanished as
therapy progressed Henrietta didn't feel
any better and to her horror her abdomen
turned from soft brown to black as coal
one day she lifted up her shirt and
showed Sadie in Margaret's and said it
felt as though the blackness be
spreading all inside the radium
treatments didn't cure Henrietta's
cancer by the fall of 1951 her body was
full of tumors in a diaphragm have
bladder cervix kidneys lungs and it was
all causing her excruciating pain she
lay in bed at Johns Hopkins and screamed
out like it was the devil of pain itself
between the treatments and the cancer
Henrietta was weak and her kidneys were
no longer flushing out dangerous toxins
in their blood she had to receive
numerous transfusions the doctors tried
different medications to ease her
suffering including morphine which
didn't even touch the pain on one
desperate attempt the doctors even
injected alcohol into her spine but
nothing seemed to work
all anyone could do was sit beside her
bed and pray
Henrietta sister Gladys was at her
bedside the night she succumbed to
cancer
knowing her time had come Henrietta made
her sister promise to take care of her
kids and whispered through tears don't
you let anything bad happen to them
children when I'm gone at 12:15 a.m. on
October the 4th 1951 Henrietta Lacks
took her last breath and died in a
hospital bed her body was sent back to
clover and buried in the family plot in
an unmarked
live next to a mother
the importance of Henriette cells cannot
be overstated
through this immortalized continuously
cultured cell line cancer research has
advanced vaccines have been developed
gene mapping has taken place and
treatments of various diseases have been
studied and undertaken HeLa cells have
even been put into space on missions
with both Americans and Russians were
tested against an atomic bomb and were
the first human cells
cloned perhaps the most well known
advances using HeLa cells occurred
shortly after Henrietta's death in the
midst of a polio epidemic the virus was
sweeping the country and parents feared
for the lives of their children in late
summer dubbed polio season public
swimming pools were shut down and
officials warned the virus could be
spread by sitting too close to others of
movie theaters by 1952 60,000 children
were infected and thousands were
paralyzed a vaccine was in development
by Jonas Salk that he needed a way to
test it in a lab on a grand scale before
injecting children HeLa provided the
perfect opportunity soon the HeLa
project at Tuskegee University began
growing the cell line employing mostly
black women lab technicians Tuskegee zhh
mass production of HeLa would serve as
the first of its kind and has helped
launched a multi-billion dollar industry
when the first commercial cell culture
operation began using Tuskegee smaadahl
in an old Fritos Factory in Bethesda
Maryland while this groundbreaking
biomedical research was taking place
only a handful of people could trace the
HeLa cell line origins back to a poor 31
year-old black woman with cervical
cancer 2 decades would pass before the
name Henrietta Lacks was finally
released to the public
[Music]
for many years members of the lacs
family never knew how Henrietta's cells
were used to advance medical research
indeed when her name was released to the
public many questions were still left
unanswered the children especially her
daughter Deborah were too young to
remember her mother ins longed to know
what she was like what a favorite color
was and whether or not she breastfed her
not knowing and not understanding how a
mother's cells could still be living
after her death was terrifying and cost
the family great anxiety and pain her
sons and husband a were mostly angry
with Johns Hopkins the doctors and
George gay day never gave the hospital
permission to use his wife cells and it
didn't seem right or fair that people
were making millions of dollars from
selling them while members of the family
couldn't even afford health insurance
Hopkins has made public statements that
the hospital is never directly profited
from he Lorenz at the time no federal
regulations were in place for obtaining
permission to use Henrietta cells for
research a book published in 2010 by
author Rebecca Skloot and movie starring
Oprah Winfrey has recently brought
greater attention to the woman behind
the immortal HeLa cells raising ethical
questions for the world to ponder for
now over 60 years after her death
Henrietta's cells live on and continue
to provide us with immeasurable value in
the fight to cure and eradicate disease
for that we can be grateful and now we
know a little bit more about the woman
Henrietta Lacks so I really hope you
enjoyed that episode of biographic if
you did there's a couple of things you
could do right now one is hit that like
button below also if you want more stuff
like this we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday so hit
that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on YouTube if you actually want to
get a notification about these videos
please do hit that Bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send
you a notification every time every
Monday and Thursday where we put out a
new video also if you want to watch
something else right now stuff from the
archive over there on the right as
always
you